Let's talk about the provisioning life cycle.
The provisioning life cycle is all about how an organization, provisions, or...
The provisioning life cycle is all about how an organization, provisions, or creates
new user accounts.
How those accounts, those users, are managed throughout their entire life cycle, their
entire time at the company, and then how finally those accounts are removed.
So when you hear about the provisioning life cycle, a three major pieces are typically
your provisioning, your review, and your revocation.
Let's talk about the first step of the provisioning life cycle.
This is where the organization will create a new account.
And that includes things like doing backgrounds checks and making sure that the employee has
the right skills for the job, and it also includes actually creating the account.
And as part of that, you should do something known as identity proofing, which means
that you're making sure the employee is who they say they are by checking passports
or driver's license or something like that.
And then finally, creating the actual account.
But the account should be created only with the principles of least privilege you need
to know.
In other words, their access has to be approved.
And who should be approving that access?
The owner.
Now, once a user has accounts or a number of accounts within the organization, the next
step of the provisioning life cycle is reviewing those accounts.
And review means that the owner or the system owner of the account should be reviewing that
account to make sure the access remains appropriate.
The final step of the provisioning life cycle is revocation.
And revocation actually includes two important parts.
Part of it might be if someone changes roles within the organization, you actually have
to not only grant them new access, but remove any existing access that they no longer need.
And revocation also includes when you finally get to leave the company, when you're dead
and you can't help anymore or you can't do any more good work, no, I mean revocation
is when you leave the company and your access needs to be removed.
And so that's the entire provisioning life cycle.
And let's just dig into a couple little pieces.
So when it comes to user access reviews, how often should they be conducted?
Who should be conducting the review?
Which accounts should be reviewed most often?
All of this falls under the review process.
And the perfect answer for who should be reviewing access to make sure that that access
is appropriate, the owners, owners of systems, of applications are the ones that should be
reviewing to make sure the access is appropriate.
And if you got a question asking you how often should access be reviewed or if you're
thinking about something like this, the incorrect answer is any specific time like once
a year or once a month or once every week.
The perfect answer is in fact actually as often as necessary based on the value of the
system.
Why is that the perfect answer?
Well, because different systems have different value to the organization, different risk profiles.
And so their users need to be reviewed at different frequencies, different cycles, different
cadences.
And so for a very high value system where there might be a lot of turnover in users, maybe
weekly reviews are appropriate.
For lower battery systems with less turnover, maybe once a month, maybe even once a year
is appropriate.
So the perfect answer is as often as necessary.
And which type of accounts should be reviewed most often?
I'll let you know the answer to this one.
High value accounts, system accounts, root accounts, those are the accounts that we want
to review most often.
And so for a very high value system with less turnover, maybe even once a year or once a year
or once a year or once a year or once a year or once a year or once a year or once a year.